[Música]
[Aplausos]
o primeiro né novamente boa tarde a todo
mundo - emanuel
tenho 38 anos é sou o verdadeiro show
nada gente honda real e vamos ser tentar
ter um pouco de seriedade
a única coisa que eu sou é filha da dona
ivanete uma negócio show de bola
sou pai de cinco filhos desses cinco
filhos três são biológicos dois são
afetivos e acho que tudo que eu tenho na
vida tudo que eu acabei construindo na
vida são dessas duas relações relações
de ser pai e de seu filho porque se de
um lado os nossos países insistem que
nós tenhamos raízes nos nossos filhos
eles estão os tempo tempo todos os
instigando até asas e como eu tenho
cinco filhos imagina que eu sou
praticamente um condon nessa situação
toda hora tem um desafio de 19 a três
meses então e eu toda hora pirando e
nessas operações nós somos convidados a
visitar realidades que a gente está na
mente visita seja jogar logo até 3 horas
da manhã o vilã santana ou te que
revisitar de ordem ou e o conceito da
revolução dos bichos e por aí vai
num dessas foi muito maluco em 300
história dos meus filhos eu fosse contar
mas sim assim que me chama muito a
atenção para esse dia de hoje é especial
é o dia que um dos meus filhos chegou em
casa dizendo que ia mais à escola numa
escola porque como esse não é meu
principal uma escola porque o meu colega
falou que não gosta de mim porque eu sou
preto um guarda no bolso preto em uma
escola quando disse não vou mais pra
escola segura sua onda segura sua onda
boa resolver essa parada aí e eu
seguindo lá pelo conceito de verdade eo
comércio em geral de recurso
a ação de mandela e desmond tutu falei
vamos reunir todo mundo vai botar todo
mundo pra conversar junto que as coisas
se acalma
aí fui me chamar o menino sean ao pai do
menino chama todo mundo bota todo mundo
da roda é bom com essa aí
ao menos em torno de perto meu nome só
perto não só negra começou aquele papo
no rapaz tem a calma todo mundo aí até a
hora que ouvi uma frase fantástica
o pai do menino de si para ele filho
você não pode falar isso e aí o menino
veio ao pai fala então vou falar o que
eu vou mentir e ficou aquele silêncio e
foi muito doido porque eu me coloquei no
lugar do menino não do meu filho somente
que no lugar do meu filho sempre tive eu
sei que preto passa obrigado eu sei o
impacto do racismo na minha vida
sabe contar isso tira um gol de letra
desde criança eu sei o que ela seja
capaz de fazer comigo eu sou nunca tinha
parado para pensar o que o racismo faz
uns brancos de monstruoso isso o que
você faz com vocês brancos chega a ser
quase tão letal quanto que ele faz
comigo e eu não sei se vocês se dão
conta disso que acontece que combateu o
racismo na boa não é me apoiar em apoiar
meu filho minha família resolveu o
melhor de vocês eu consigo sobreviver
com isso desculpa 22 anos era morador de
rua e eu trabalho numa empresa de
comunicação desse país
estou muito bem com a minha cor como é
que vocês resolve porque vamos lá o que
a pessoa precisa para ser racista nesse
país gente que a pessoa precisa para ser
racista e quando eu tô falando disso eu
não tô falando porque o racismo é um
problema dos pretos não é um problema
nosso é um problema da sociedade como um
todo ea minha intenção é que nesses
próximos três minutos a gente possa
entender
por que o racismo é um problema mais de
vocês do que meu
na boa na hora que não fica bom pega o
avião voou para a áfrica do sul e voltou
a cantar bumba boi bumbá e conrado na
mata e estou feliz pra caramba
o pepino continua na mão de vocês pra
ser racista aquele menino me mostrar uma
coisa
pai eu vou mentir ou seja ele tem que
ser mentiroso né
é que eu não posso numa sociedade como a
nossa vir a dizer quase preto
posso dizer isso que só fala o mago de
se expulsar qualquer ambiente estiver
mal a primeira coisa que eu preciso
ensinar para o meu filho branco se eu
quiser que ele vá bem é que ele precisa
saber mentir
ele precisa ser dissimulado quando
chegar um preto e oi moreninho tudo bem
querido precisa saber fazer isso porque
senão vai transitar
ele precisa ser hipócrita e falar uma
coisa e sentiu outra vez fazem idéia de
como se léza a personalidade o caráter
de um indivíduo fazendo isso porque o
menino ele não cresce sendo hipócrita
mentiroso falso cínico dissimulado ele
não cresce assim mais para conviver com
essa prática ele precisa desenvolver
esses mecanismos para poder ficar de pé
o maior lesado naquela situação não era
meu filho era o filho do cara era ele
que estava sendo lesado e eu comecei a
pensar falei cara um jec tal cern disso
porque nessa nós vamos analisá a
escravidão foi abolida 130 anos 130 anos
de nada se não falando de duas gerações
e meia ou seja há 130 anos e eu me
comprar por 400 reais e levar pra casa
mas vocês vão fazer o que quisesse mas
europa
a gente está falando de nada
historicamente é um salto muito curto é
um salto pequeno mas quando nós
analisamos que nós estamos praticamente
na frente do teletransporte
parece que estamos extremamente
atrasados
eu acho a sociedade brasileira uma das
mais avançadas na questão racial porque
nós não só conseguimos sobreviver que
matar essa negra não é fácil apesar do
genocídio e olha denuncie de uma
violência ao fascismo que dizem que está
por aí né gente
com essa dúvida atualmente nós temos um
problema mesmo assim conseguimos ficar
de pé
quando nós começamos a analisar tudo que
nós tiramos dos filhos dos detentores de
poder para que eles possam exercer o seu
racismo
vemos que estamos construindo uma
sociedade doente doente porque ele
cresce mentiroso dissimulados em caráter
desrespeitoso falso só para poder ser
racista aonde é que está o problema
e aí me veio com uma epifania
o problema está na frase do pai e filho
você não pode dizer isso não é filho
você não pode pensar assim não é filho
precisamos redesenhar que você está
falando filho sua opinião está errada é
filho você não pode dizer eu estou
proibindo o meu filho assista de ser
verdadeiro enquanto ser ao invés de fizi
bizarra o problema acessá-lo desconstruí
lo eu estou impedindo essa criança de
ter uma transformação real eu estou
dizendo para ele filho seja cínico
mentiroso seja dissimulado finja que
gosta dele
é isso que estou dizendo para essa
criança quando essa criança cresce ela
cresce com esses valores estão entre
sicos que quando falar para ela puxa o
que você fez o racismo não eu não sou
racista porque interiorizou de maneira
tão profunda essa pseudo a verdade é que
ele começa a acreditar nele não tem mais
condições de enxergar o que é real ea
partir daí nós compomos o que é o
racismo estrutural para ser racista você
precisa ser uma pessoa ruim na sua
génese na sua segunda infância além dos
6 aos seus 12 anos de idade
você precisa ser assim e aí é muito
doido que quando você pergunta no
cliente quem aqui acha que existe
racismo todos levantam a mão quando você
pergunta quem aqui é racista ninguém
levanta a mão porque as pessoas
reconhecem que isso existe mas
reconhecem isso dentro de si
isso é um problema quando essas pessoas
vão para dentro das suas empresas
eles levam consigo essas mesmas mazelas
esses mesmos defeitos de caráter que
foram adquiridos com o racismo
aí você pega um profissional mentiroso
dissimulado falso
tudo isso poderia ter sido eliminado lá
na base mas não é você quer realmente me
convencer que o problema de tudo está na
questão racial
sim meu amor porque foi na questão
racial que nós desenhamos a estrutura
social deste país foi em cima dessa
relação racial em cima da relação de
poderes não não é mas existem outros
tipos de preconceito você tem um
preconceito com o que você tem um
preconceito com o judeu fim mas o judeu
e um gay pode fingir que não é gay não é
judeu eu não posso indicar não sou preto
né
eu vou chegar no lugar vai dizer o que
pois é eu sou agnóstico tem como querido
o meu problema é acessível
aos olhos a partir daí eu faço o que eu
preciso requalificar o olho do
preconceituoso
eu preciso investir nessa nova geração e
digo vocês poderia vir aqui contando
inúmeras histórias situações de racismo
dramáticas da minha vida mas eu não sei
até onde reforçar essa condição de
vítima não acaba contribuindo ainda mais
com o problema não que eu não acredite
na vitimização porque ele existe e eu
tenho marcas físicas dela mas o que eu
acredito ainda mais é que quem precisa
está com a luz em cima dele vestindo a
roupa de problema
não sou eu não são as minhas cicatrizes
que as pessoas precisam ver elas
precisam ver a cicatriz no caráter do
racista
quem tem que sentar no banco pra ouvir
pra se expor a abrir a sua mazela para
sangrar o seu peito e tentar retirar
esse pois é ele e não eu então não venha
me pergunta a nossa como você fez pra
ter orgulho da sua cor não querido como
é que você fez pra ter raiva da minha
cor orgulho da minha já tem um faz tempo
minha mãe me ensinou isso desde criança
enquanto nós não ver termos esse eixo
nós vamos continuar exercendo uma
postura covarde
hoje você questionar você focar a
questão racial no negro é a mesma coisa
de você dizer que a menina foi estuprada
porque a saia dela era curta é a mesma
coisa
vamos parar de responsabilizar de
visibilizar a vítima de fazer dela a
cara do problema e isso é algo que
precisamos evoluir com naturalidade
gente nós estamos há 130 anos da
abolição da escravatura ou começamos
agora esse processo ou não vamos mais
conseguir fazer
quando dizemos que o racismo não é um
problema de uma etnia
mas se o problema de uma sociedade é
porque associa essa sociedade não vai
conseguir avançar
nós não vamos dar um passo à frente se
não for naturalizada a relação com
negros
eu não estou dizendo que eu quero que
vocês se construam a kanda ea partir daí
tire um princípio de xalapa tocar o
bonde é isso que eu estou falando não
estou dizendo que vocês quando entra no
ambiente precisam contar quantos negros
têm e se vocês entrarem nesse ambiente e
nesse ambiente tiver pouco negro isso
precisa se diz confortável pra vocês
no avião que estava hoje de manhã tinha
dois deles estavam trabalhando e eu tô
contando comigo vocês não fazem idéia de
como é desconfortável para nós sermos o
único do lugar
eu adoro a áfrica sempre que possível
pega o avião e vou pra lá porque na
áfrica eu não sou negro na áfrica do sul
só uma pessoa
vocês não fazem idéia de como é isso
quando você chega num ambiente você não
é o senso comum de como é você ver a
representação de uma peça publicitária
ea primeira coisa que o publicitário
pensa é no branco é ter o magro não é na
gente que eles pensam
quando rola um desenho animado nós não
somos figura desse desenho
nós não existimos e não fazem ideia do
que é você sentar na cadeira da escola
tem uma figura de jesus cristo entender
que o filho de deus o homem mais
importante disso tudo não se parece com
você
nada se parece com você
com exceção do bandido amanhã mas a
coisa está mudando olha só nós temos aí
atores atrizes que estão bombando gente
séria que vamos jogar o mundo pela
exceção é sério vamos jogar o mundo pela
seleção
vocês querem fazer e olha que nós
estamos em um espaço acadêmico que é
super inclusivo e revolucionário
dentro de uma das cidades mais
importantes do mundo favor quem for
negro levante a mão quem for branco
levante a mão
desculpa nós temos menos de 20% de preto
sentado nessa platéia e olha que isso é
um espaço de excelência inclusão fazem
idéia do tamanho do abismo que nós ainda
temos que vencer
a pergunta que eu acabo deixando com
muito carinho com muito afeto com muito
respeito é onde é que você que está
sentado aí guarda o seu racismo o que me
foi dito quando criança que você não
podia dizer na questão racial e que você
não diz nem para você nem para os seus
filhos
você tem coragem de olhar no seu filho e
filho para com isso que você está sendo
racista
você tem coragem de olhar no olho do seu
filho dizer isso tem coragem de olhar no
olho de seu funcionário dizer isso com
tranquilidade sim que na hora de
esfregar verdades na nossa cara a
sociedade é muito corajosa
olha você é legal isso a gente ouve com
freqüência
eu realmente gostaria que nós
responderemos essa pergunta pra nós
mesmos porque assim como disse o grande
luther king eu sonho com o dia em que as
pessoas não serão julgadas pela cor da
sua pele mas isso vai demorar um pouco
de tempo ainda ea grande questão é o que
nós precisamos para deixar de ser
racistas porque racistas todos nós somos
é impossível crescer no brasil viver no
brasil existe no brasil e não ser
racista
obrigado pelo carinho pela atenção de
vocês eu peço desculpas se fez
assim
[Aplausos]